is that how your tv show came about they
they loved you on gary moore this and
that cbs signs you to a holding deal
back in those days like a five-year
holding deal in order to get paid
you have to come up with a show no how
did it work
uh it was a weird contract they gave the
10-year contract
and it was within the first five years
the agent who worked this out was a
genius
because it's i don't think ever been
done before or since
and within the first five years if i
chose to do a variety show cbs would
have to put it on whether they wanted to
or not
30 one-hour shows pay or play you must
have been in some good position to get a
contract like that unbelievable
i mean you were that well thought of
that at that time yeah what a crazy
contract and the networks you talk about
now networks now aren't so important
then it was the only three networks what
a deal
well i never thought i would want to do
it
i can't be a variety that's not in me to
do that
so lap dissolve i'm married
and i'm as cold you're married to joe
that's your second husband right yeah
and
uh i'm as cold now as as i was hot
five years before and so we're sitting
around
you know we bought a house in california
and
it was the last week of the fifth year
and uh we had five day five days to go
and we said you know maybe we better
push that button
because if you don't push the button no
pace so because you were cold
your career wasn't going great you say
okay let's come up with some show
yeah and the show you come up with is
the carol burnett show variety show and
your thinking was i don't want to do a
sitcom where i play the same character
i want to show where i can show off that
i can play many many characters right
and so this great show kind of evolves
out of that right
cbs didn't want it because you were
called yeah then they tried to talk me
out of it to do a sitcom called here's
agnes
agnes lovely picture it here's agnes
was the script horrible for here's agnes
no i wouldn't even read it because i
said no i want to be
i want to do different variety is what i
love like i want to do
the sid caesar show right i want a rep
company i want singers and dancers
sketches and they have to give it to you
because they have a contract
they had too did they give you a crappy
time slot at first well
in a way i was opposite big valley and i
spy
which is two these are two killer shows
and you probably say to yourself okay
look at least i'll get a couple of weeks
on the air they'll cancel 30
and i'll have 30 shows right and that'll
be
it that's right and how soon did the
show become a hit where you're kicking i
spy's ass
well we didn't kick their ass exactly
but we did very well
and uh it was within the first month
does the network's attitude change
toward you
yes and they moved me to the big
saturday night which was
that was powerhouse went with um oh
god uh all in the family mash
yes mary tyler moore what a lineup bob
newhart
and us so then you become this
powerhouse because the lineup is so
killer you're all feeding off of each
other wow